visitor budget I had a second Granger
[Music]
Beaverton came at akashavani to Sonali
Ganton he delegate and mechanical okie
binary Manticore sorta deep in the
Himalayan mountains about 80 miles
outside of Katmandu the Bujang village
takes part in a death-defying tradition
all in the name of honey yada yadi but
I'm gonna journey or not it's on the oh
honey can we stone that it but procuring
this precious honey takes more than just
strength a team of honey hunters
assembles twice a year to prepare and
Madan he leads the pack Wylie you just
the Emerald gam je jure here are your
gum time system oil you hear about how
you gotta go
you're a man a cop even a movie theater
of this deep pass an online today
ancient customs are still closely
followed before each hunt Madan must
visit the village guru to receive His
blessing guru Pinheiro Buddha by oh no
no secobarbital et cetera
I was a legend era tikka masala dhaba
two Arab armies we come gotta janja
[Music]
one day Madan will fill the Guru's shoes
in the meantime he leads his team of
honey hunters into the jungle the team
braids and Bree secures their handmade
rope ladders
then they ventured to the cliff side
where the beehives are hiding the team
creates smoke fires down below to
encourage the giant bees to scatter
Madan lowers himself onto the Rope
dangling hundreds of feet from the
ground
Oh Moira and uncle Natalie League or
very much a varsity mammarra layali
acrimony garden to tell a tomorrow miss
Toller Molly given nearby or debated le
garite le meriden mother bunny poor
Emily what is it amalgam I get my limo
team despite the incessant stinging on
his unprotected skin he calmly cuts away
at the hive fulfilling his duty and
securing his liquid gold forever
daddy I have a ninja turtle fancier but
it's offered it around a little deliver
him
the hives are collected by the hunters
and packed up to bring back to the
village where their safe return is
celebrated yo Ramiro Genma Diego dynamo
Mira Bobby Lea and Lea nedra Malaysians
actively any other corny porta you
Millie you you can wear a mullet ekdam
in sadita he put on Ronnie Kalen butter
our poor Connie whatever you
Morrigan challenging baka Raja
[Music]